bonjour maroonie de quoi va-t-on parler
aujourd'hui
je te fais découvrir les pattes de
Saint-Pierre
alors venez avec moi
[Musique]
nous sommes allés pattes de Saint-Pierre
un établissement chaleureux qui permet
d'assurer le bien-être de nos grammes
par une prise en charge totale alors on
rencontre de Marie Rosemay qui va nous
en dire un peu plus
bon Jean-Marie
personnelle tout ça sont bien et il y
aurait pas aussi bien aussi
la viande parfois poisson mais c'est
bien d'accord et puis je vois que vous
faites aussi les activités oui activité
j'ai fait des coloriages des faits
découpage et puis après coup de jus
c'est une coupure
et comment s'est passé justement
longtemps avec les autres ou c'est des
blagues
merci beaucoup malheureusement
c'était pas dispose d'une unité protégée
Alzheimer les équipes de la résidence
œuvrent au quotidien pour le bien-être
des résidents en leur proposant à des
soins personnalisés une vie sociale
stimulante adaptée aux Anglais chacun de
qualité bonjour Cassandre
qui peut résilier cette EHPAD et quels
sont les démarches à suivre alors pour
pouvoir résider dans cette EHPAD il faut
avoir plus de 60 ans et ne plus vouloir
ou ne plus pouvoir rester à son domicile
et comme tu le vois à la Résidence on a
la chance d'avoir une partie de nos
places qui sont habilités à l'aide
sociale qui permet à des personnes qui
n'auraient pas forcément des moyens
financiers voilà pour pouvoir payer dans
la totalité les frais en institution et
donc ils peuvent faire une demande
d'aide sociale auprès du Département et
donc le département ce sera lui qui
prendra en charge l'ensemble des frais
d'hébergement avec quand même une
participation des familles et des
obligés alimentaires ça permet à tous
les Réunionnais de pouvoir bénéficier de
la résidence Saint-Pierre merci
marronnier
dispositif les agents du Département
œuvrent au quotidien pour le bien-être
des personnes âgées dépendantes et moins
dépendantes ou toutes les autres
personnes de la situation le nécessite
les établissements médico-sociaux pour
les personnes âgées sont réparties sur
le département il existe 25 structures
d'hébergement sur l'île et six
accueillent de jour et il y a 1926
places d'accueil au sein de ces
structures il est prévue la création de
500 places d'hébergement permanent en
EHPAD pour ces prochaines années
l'aide sociale à l'hébergement est une
aide versée par le Département aux
usagers des établissements
médico-sociaux ne disposant pas de
ressources suffisantes pour assurer les
frais de séjour la SH peut prendre en
charge tout ou partie du loyer
hébergement et du tarif dépendant la
demande esth peut-être faite auprès du
département ou des CCAS lors de
l'évaluation de la SH et les tenues
compte des ressources des objets
alimentaires l'obligation alimentaire
est due par les descendants pour les
ascendants de la personne en fonction de
leurs ressources aussi par décision du
département aucun recours se succession
n'est établi dans le cadre de la SH
si vous souhaitez avoir plus
d'informations sur l'aide sociale à
l'hébergement n'hésitez pas les
coordonnées s'affichent en bas de votre
écran voilà le département des
générations c'est fini
épisode précédent rendez-vous sur le
site et nous réseaux sociaux quant à moi
je vous retrouve très vite pour un
nouvel épisode à bientôt
[Musique]